사나미 간다 오늘은 청남동 명품거리에
와 있습니다 최근에 명품거리가 되게
좀 좋아지고 있는데 이런 명품거리가
좀 어떻게 변하고 있는지 여러분들한테
좀 소개해 드리고 명품거리의 투자
전망이라는 부동산 꿀팁까지
준비했으니까이 영상 계속 시청해
주시면 감사하겠습니다 본격적으로 좀
보도록
[음악]
하시죠네 우선 청남동 명품거리 역사에
대해서 좀 설명을 드리자면 어
갤러리와 백화전 명품관을 시작으로
명품거리가 좀 생겨나 시작했습니다
그리고 서울시에서 여기를 할리스타
거리로 조성을 하면서이 명품 매장들이
좀 많이 들어오기 시작했고 여기
인근에는 압구정 현대라는 고급 주거가
좀 많이 밀집되어 있어요 부유층들이
많이 거주하면서 이쪽 상권을 많이 좀
이용하게 됐습니다 그러다가
2018년도에 상권이 좀 많이
몰락하기 시작을 했는데 그때 당시
아직도 저도 기억하는게 인대 현수막이
워낙 많이 붙혀져 있었어요 불과 6년
전만 하더라도 거의 한 다섯 개 건물
중에 한 개 건물은 비어 있을 정도로
거의 20% 이상 공실률이 되게
높았습니다 그러다가 최근 분위기는
완전 많이 바뀌었어요 임대 현수막을
볼 수 없을 정도로 많은 건물들이 다
꽉 차 있고 그리고 여기 제가
걸어봤는데 한 여덟 개 아홉 개
건물을 지금 공사 중에 있습니다 이제
일본에 가면은 약간 그 오모테산도 럼
화려한 명품 건물들이 좀 많이
생겨나고 있어요 임대료도 좀 많이
올라가고 있고 이쪽으로 원래 이제
건물 찾는 분들이 요즘에 좀 많이
생겨나고 있습니다 근데 여기 거리
자체가 건물이 워낙 한정돼 있다
보니까 부르는게 진짜 갑이에요
임대료도 부르는게 갑입니다 그만큼
되게 좀 희소성이 있는 위치라고 좀
보시면 될 거 같습니다네 그래서 뭐
특징 있는 건물을 좀 설명드리자면 그
SM 이수만 대표님 건물이 이쪽
대로변에 있는 건물을 99년도에
매입을 했어요 그래 99년도 하더라도
아가 끝난지 얼마 되지 않은 그런
시계였는데 건물 아무도 사지 않을
시기였습니다 그때 이제 매입을
해가지고 소문에 의하면 한 20억
원대 산 걸로 알고 있거든요 그래서
그 건물을 매입해서 추가로 이제 뒷
건물까지 매입하고 그다음에 그 옆에
붙어 있는 건물도 최근에 150억
원에 사 가지고 그 건물들을 다
합쳤습니다 총 대지면적이 한 430평
정도 됩니다 근데 지금 그 위치를
SM 현재 지금 성수동으로 옮겼고
청담동 명품거리 있는 위치를 지금
멸실하고
마이바흐 매장으로 들어올 예정입니다
그래서 지금 효성에서 마이바흐 뭐
플래그십 매장으로 쓰려고 지금 건물을
신축 중에 있는 것으로 보입니다 지금
저도 몰랐는데 마이바흐를 우리나라
사람들이 참 많이 사더라고 중국과
비교했을 때 인구 대비했을 때
마이바우 판매율은 오히려 우리나라가
더 높더라고요 중국보다 그만큼
세계적으로 마이바우 소비를 우리나라
사람들이 굉장히 많이 하는 거
같습니다 그래서 그만큼 되게 매력을
느끼고 이쪽에 럭셔리한 건물을 짓지
않을까 이렇게 좀 예상을 하고
있습니다네 그리고 여러분들이 좀 많이
궁금해하실 것 같은데 청남동
명품거리가 앞으로 어떻게 될지 좀
궁금해하 시는 분들이 있을 것
같습니다 건물 투자의 팁은 아까 제가
이수만 대표님 좀 말씀드렸었는데 그
뒤에 걸 샀잖아요 뒤에 있는 다가구
주택 두 개 동을 샀습니다 그래 그걸
삼으로 인해서 합치면 같이 대로변
가격을 받을 수 있거든요 그래서
만약에 여러분들이 그렇게 대로변
건물을 산다 아니면 가지고 있다라고
하면 뒤에 있는 건물들을 한번 작업을
해 보셔야 돼요 그래서 만약에 그거를
싸게만 살 수 있다면 사기만 해도
시세 차액을 보실 수 있습니다 그런
팁을 좀 말씀드리고 싶고 명품거리를
예를 들면 땅은 딱 한정돼 있고
수요는 계속 들어오고 있고 청남동
명품거리 같은 경우에는 공급이 한정돼
있는데 수요가 되게 탄탄한 곳입니다
어찌됐든 가격은 수요와 공급에 따라서
이루어지는데 공급은 없는데 수요는
많이 있는 거예요 그래서 가격은 점차
올라갈 수밖에 없고요 그래서
장기적으로 봤을 때는 가격이 계속
오를 수밖에 없습니다 저는 제일
무서운게 돈의 가치가 떨어지는 거예요
올해 1월부터 4월까지 기사를 보시면
한 7% 정도 원화가치가 떨어졌습니다
그만큼 되게 돈은 계속 내고 있잖아요
공급이 계속 많아지고 있고 명품거리
있는 땅을 늘릴 순 없잖아요 그런
점에서 저는 되게 매력이 있다라고니다
돈이 생기면 공급은 한정돼 있는데
수요가 많은데 돈을 넣어야 된다라고
생각을 하거든요 그래서 청담등심
거리라는 아니면 여기 뭐 도산
대로라는 해외로 치자면 마이애미 비치
앞에 있는 그런 부동산이라는 아니면
뉴욕 뭐 맨하탄에 되게 입지 좋은
곳이라든지 뭐 센트럴 파크 앞이라는
이렇게 공급은 한정돼 있는데 수요가
많은 데에다가 부동 산을 넣어야지
자산 가치를 좀 지킬 수 있다라고
생각을 합니다 근데 청담동 명품거리가
딱 그런 것 같아요 오늘 알려 드렸던
팁은 만약에 뒤에 땅을 싸게 살 수
있으면 무조건 사야 됩니다 사 가지고
같이 묶기만 해도 가치가 좀
올라간다라고 알고 계시면 될 거 같고
그리고 공급이 한정되 있는데 수요가
많은데 부동산을 사셔야지 가치가 계속
올라갑니다 그래서이 점을 좀
기억하셨다가 여러분들 투자하는데
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠습니다네 그래서
제가 좀 청당동 명품거리를 좀
설명드렸는데 앞으로의 청남동 명품
거리가 좀 어떻게 변할지 그리고 저는
지금뿐만 아니라 여기 인근에 재건축이
뭐 언제 될지 모르겠지만 만약에
된다라고 하면 진짜 몇백억 넘는
아파트들이 굉장히 많이 생겨날 겁니다
그래서 실제로 지금도 많이 생겨나고
있고 수요층이 저는 더 탄탄해질 거
같고 가격이 더 올라갈 거 같아요
마이애미 비치에 있는 부동산처럼
아니면 맨하탄 센트럴 파크 앞에 있는
부동산처럼 공급은 한정돼 있지만
엄청난 수요가 몰로 곳이라고 저는
생각을 합니다네 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요 청담동 명품거리가
앞으로 어떻게 변화할지 좀 여러분들
지켜봐 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
그래서 여러분들이 혹시 생각하시는
그런 상권 분석이라는 전망이라는 좀
궁금한게 있으시면 댓글 남겨 주시면
제가 찾아가서 분석이라는 앞으로
어떻게 될 건지 제 의견을 좀
드리도록 하겠습니다 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 여러분들이
영상이 마음에 드셨다면 구독과 좋아요
눌러 주시고 건물은 역시 사남
k
[음악]